I told you from the start that I'm not
going to engage in what I consider to be
destructive Democratic primary smears
I'm gonna stick to the facts and the
truth is that sometimes the facts just
aren't great for particular candidates
so as an example from last week or maybe
it was the week before
Beto O'Rourke had no lobbyists as a
pledge on his website and in his
fundraising emails and Beto got caught
taking money from lobbyists and very
quickly the no lobbyists pledge
disappeared from the website and it was
gone overnight from dedos fundraising
emails and I pointed out that this is a
factual reality and it might influence
whether you want to support that
O'Rourke or not it's not a smear it's
reporting on realities Joe Biden raised
a ton of money last week as I told you
earlier this week and a lot of that
money it was from big-money donors
high-priced fundraisers including the
executive vice president of Comcast he
has a Google CEO fundraiser next month
these are not smears it's important to
understand that different candidates are
funded in different ways it's relevant
to how they will govern so I'm going to
tell you about it and similarly mayor
Pete Budaj
has been caught taking lobbyist
donations and is now saying that he's
going to be returning the money to the
lobbyists and from now on going forward
he definitely is not going to be
accepting their money 39 individuals
registered as lobbyists donated just
over $30,000 to Mayor Pete's so far and
the campaign says it's going to be
returning the 30k and also banning
registered lobbyists from serving as
bundlers for the campaign bundler czar
these people who know a lot of donors
and they'll bundle together large
numbers of donations where the total is
way more than an individual is allowed
to donate but they bundle it from a
whole bunch of people and they bring in
a lot of money for candidates
unfortunately this seems to be a change
that Pete Buda judge is making because
he got caught and it looks bad not
because he actually thinks is wrong to
take lobbyist money and there is really
much more to talk about in this battle
on campaign funding because there are
candidates who
you might make the decision to limit
their campaign to small donations but
people can still make multiple small
donations to get around that limit
corporate money
what about accepting corporate money or
not accepting corporate money or PAC
money or lobbyist money and the point I
want to make is that this is why we
cover candidates and their funding
ideally when we cover how candidates are
funded it gets them to make the right
decisions but that really only applies
up to a point because as I've said
before you've got to balance this with
strategy if the other side takes all
contributions in the general election
it's going to be tough to win without at
least taking some of that money in the
general election so this is why I'm okay
taking the position now that in the
primary you do one thing and whatever
you say you're going to do you'd better
damn well do it but in the general
election if you're the nominee I think
you have to consider what it is that's
going to get you the win does the
progressive movement benefit by putting
up a candidate against Trump who's going
to disavow so much money that they then
lose in 2020 Wow really great they
didn't take any of that money they did
the right thing I love it except they
lost and now we get four more years of
Trump was that worth it and I don't know
what the answer is so first of all we
have a poll about this on our YouTube
community tab go to youtube.com slash
the david pakman show slash community
and vote on what you think is the right
sort of financial decision that
candidates should make in the primary
and then in the general election as far
as mayor Pete getting caught he got
caught he changed the policy you can
view it as he's a great guy for making
the right decision after getting caught
or you can view him as sort of
disingenuous
saying he's only doing this because he
got caught either way there's got to be
an accounting for the general election
because I don't want any of the money in
politics all of this stuff is toxic and
destructive and I wanted out but I also
recognized that if the Democratic
nominee rejects all of it the Democratic
nominee almost
definitely loses to trump in 2020 so let
me know what you think something we talk
about frequently on the show is the
alarming rate at which online freedom
and online privacy are diminishing
social media companies search engine
companies internet service providers are
tracking your every move
governments and websites are censoring
content in many countries and the
solution is something called a VPN which
makes you anonymous when you're online
by changing your computer's IP address
and the only VPN to earn a perfect
rating from PC Magazine is Nord VPN
which is one of today's David Pakman
show sponsors and Nord VPN is giving
everybody in our audience a 75% discount
on a three-year subscription this comes
out to under three dollars a month plus
you'll get a whole month free when you
go to Nord VPN comm slash David Pakman
and use coupon code david pakman all one
word Nord VPN encrypts and anonymizes
all of your internet traffic it keeps
your web activity and your data totally
private it keeps your data safe from
hackers it protects you when you're on
public Wi-Fi when you don't know who is
trying to spy on you or steal your
information and you can get around
government censorship which might
especially become an issue for our
audience in Europe we're still not sure
how the new EU copyright laws are going
to affect access to websites like
YouTube you can use Nord VPN on pretty
much any of your devices that connects
to the internet your computer your phone
your tablet even your TV they have an
awesome Chrome browser plug-in which
I've been using and I love and david
pakman show viewers can get 75% off a
three-year plan of Nord VPN that's under
three bucks a month plus one whole month
totally free just by going to Nord VPN
comm slash David Pakman I put the link
underneath this video then just use the
coupon code David Pakman at checkout all
one word